you can use a hammer to go and hit
somebody with it right I'm not I'm not
saying every technology
is equally destructive or what have you
but you can conceive of it's kind of
like rule 34 but for technology right
you okay right you can you can probably
figure out the ability to reference
brilliant things throughout is quite
admirable yes but anyway sorry rule 34
for technology rule three four but for
abusive technology you can always come
up with a black mirror version of
something and in fact there is this kind
of funny tweet which is like a Sci-Fi
author my book don't invent the torment
Nexus was meant to be a cautionary Tale
on what you know would happen if Society
invented the torment neckness and then
it's like uh Tech guys at long last we
have created the torment Nexus right and
uh so the thing is that simply
describing something some abuse
unfortunately
um after the initial shock wears off
people will unconsciously think of it as
sort of an attractor in the space right
it's like I'll give you some examples
like uh you know Minority Report had the
gesture thing right and the connect was
based on that so it's a dystopian movie
but had this cool kind of thing and
people you know kind of keyed off it
right or you know people have said that
movies like um you know full metal
jacket that was meant to be in my my
understanding is meant to be like an
anti-war movie but lots of you know
soldiers just love it you know despite
the fact that the drill sergeants
actually depicted as a bad guy right for
the sort of portrayal of that you know
kind of kind of environment right so I'm
just saying it's like giving the vision
of like the digital Hitler or whatever
is not actually a vision I want to paint
I do think is it is it everything is
it's possible obviously you know isis
uses the internet right like is it yeah
I'm not we're not bringing up Hitler
in a shallow argument we're bringing up
Hitler in a long empathetic relaxed
discussion which is which is where
Hitler can live in a healthy way so that
there is a there's deep left lessons in
Hitler and Nazi Germany absolutely
Stalin yes okay so in many ways uh you
know and this is a very superficial way
of talking about it but this is
um exit is the anti-genocide technology
right because exit is the route of the
politically powerless exit is not people
always say oh exit is for the rich or
that's actually not true most immigrant
most immigrants equals most immigrants
are not rich they're politically
powerless you describe exit what is exit
so uh there's this you know book which I
reference a lot I like it um called exit
voice and loyalty by Albert hirschman
okay and he essentially says
um and you know I give this talk uh in
2013 that that goes through this uh at
uh uh YC start school but just to
describe these
voices reform exits alternatives for
example in the context of an open source
project voices uh submitting a bug and
exit is forking in a company
um voices uh you're saying you know hey
uh here's a
um here's a ticket okay that I'd like to
get solved and exit is taking your
business elsewhere okay
um you know at level corporate
governance voices you know board
directors vote and exit is selling your
shares right in a country voices a vote
and exit is migration okay and
um I do think that the two forces we
talk about a lot democracy and
capitalism are useful forces
um but there's a third which is uh
migration right so you can vote with
your ballot you vote with your wallet
you can vote your feet wallet has some
aspects of exit built into it
um but voting your feet actually has
some aspects of voice built into it
because when you leave it's like an
amplifier on your vote you might say 10
things but you actually leave then
people take what you said seriously
you're not just like complaining or
whatever you you actually left San
Francisco because it was so bad on this
and this issue and you've actually voted
with your feet it is
um manifest preference as opposed to
state of preference so Voice versus exit
is this interesting dichotomy do you try
to reform the system or do you exit it
and build a new one or seek an
alternative and then loyalty modulates
this where if you are a patriot as part
of your the initial part of your
conversation right like you know uh are
you are you a Trader you know you're
giving up on our great thing or whatever
right
and you know people push those buttons
to get people to stick that's like you
know I should say the bad version let's
say a common version Sometimes good
sometimes bad
um then uh but then there's the good
version which is oh you know maybe the
price is down right now but you believe
in the cause so even if they're uh you
know on paper you you would rationally
exit you believe in in this thing and
you're gonna stick with it okay so
loyalty can be again good and bad but it
kind of modulates the trade-off between
voice and exit Okay so given that
framework we can think of a lot of
problems in terms of am I going to use
voice or exit or some combinations are
because they're not mutual so if it's
kind of like you know left and right
sometimes you need both together
I think that one of the biggest things
the internet does is it increases
microeconomic Leverage
and therefore increases exit in every
respect of life for example
um you know on every phone you can pick
between Lyft and Uber right when you're
at the store uh you see a price on the
shelf and you can comparison shop right
um if it's Tinder you can swipe right if
it's Twitter you can click over to the
next account the back button is exit the
The microeconomic Leverage leverage in
the sense of Alternatives right this is
like the one of the fundamental things
that the internet does it puts this tool
on your desktop and now you can go and
talk to an illustrator or you can kind
of build it yourself right by by typing
in some you know characters into Dolly
and that makes the positive forces of
capitalism more efficient uh increase in
microeconomic leverage and it's
individual empowerment right and so our
sort of Industrial Age systems were not
set up for that level of individual
empowerment just to give you like one
example they think about we take for
granted every single website you go and
log into you can configure your Twitter
profile and you can make it it dark mode
or light mode and your name all this
stuff is editable right how do you
configure your USA experience
is there a usa.gov that you edit can you
even edit your name there dark mode for
USA but I mean just your profile is
there is there like a national profile I
mean there's like driver's license point
is that it's assumed that it's not like
individually customizable quite in that
way right of course you can move around
your house and stuff like that but it's
not like your experience of the US is
like configurable